我发现只要先把图做成这样的分镜故事版
再和原图一起去生日
创作效率会有质的变化
刚才我还放了一张这样的身份版
或者叫角色设定版
它能让人物在各种复杂的警别运动下
也维持特征不保险
用原图限定风格场景
故事版限定警别与运动
身份版限定角色细节
我只增加了两张图
就基本告别了视频中卡
今天教你这套非常好用的视频制作技巧
案例提示词都整理好了
大家可以直接讨
我拿LeapTV举例
带你快速的过一篇流程
这里面原图是自己的
身份版提示词是通用的
整个流程就只有故事版提示词
跟视频提示词需要我们重新做一下
以这张猫咪跳舞的图为例
先拉一个图片节点
把这段提示词复制进来
身份版就做好了
这张图在传统三十图的基础上
包含了更多的细节
增加了各种运动的姿态
甚至是连眼睛
爪子
毛发
这些很微小的特征
也都被固化下来了
你可以理解为
这相当于给视频做了份角色档案
后面无论它怎么跳怎么转
镜头怎么切
都能很好地维持住
根据大家不同的场景需求
这里有几个维持一致性的工具
也很好用
如果你的剧情
偏向于人物的近景描写
可以用角色脸部三十图
增加对面部表情的把握
如果想要一个镜头下的不同视角
多其位行动格就非常好用
针对运动简单的镜头
其实直接用角色三十图
也能得到不错的效果
商品广告类的话
就直接用产品算式图就好
这些都是不需要提示词的
一键就能完成
大家自行体验
下面我们来制作故事版提示词
在原图后边拉一个文本节点
案例里的这个提示词
是不能直接用的
但是我们可以利用语言模型能力
去套用它的内容结构
比如我把它连过来
提示词可以写
根据参考图人物形象
和文本节点中的提示词结构
不用仅仅帮我重新生成一段
什么什么的12功课分定提示词
比如这里边就可以写
让猫咪跳breaking
这样故事版提示词就有了
后边拉一个图像节点
记得把原图也拉进来做参考
试下效果
通过这张图
我们就可以提前
Guy的视频的全貌了
每一格都是一个镜头
哪里是进景
哪里是全身
哪里是旋转
哪里是定格
情趣和动作都已经提前排好了
再看画面上这些小箭头
橙色代表高光跟轮廓光的方向
红色代表肢体运动方向
蓝色代表摄影机运动的方向
这些不是后期加热玩的
而是在提示词环节就已经约定好了
比如小猫做风车旋转的这个镜头
需要逆时针旋转
摄像机从画面的左上开始
向右下拼音
这样不光模型好理解
对于我们而言也更有画面感
这个方法就有点像
真实影视更化行业里面的画面教本
老演一般会在开拍前
先把镜头动作
空间关系跟节奏画出来
AI也是一样的
你让它直见生日评
它的理解压力也会很大
手绘的方式不仅降低了模型的负担
也更有利于它去稳定的执行
那以后抽卡做视频就可以变成抽卡做故事版了
不仅节省时间
翻车也不会肉腾
制作效率提升一大截
目前三张图都已经准备好了
在正式出视频前
还需要基于这个故事版
写一个视频提示词
方式跟前面类似
拉一个文本节点
把案例里女孩看视频的这个视频提示词
拉进来做参考
提示词可以写
根据图片以及文本节点中的提示词结构
帮我重新编写一段详细版的视频提示词
围绕参考独一的方式去提示词
之后我们再加一个视频节点
把三式图都连接进来做参考
再把刚才的视频提示词缠接进来
这里要注意
我们需要手动把提示词里
at后面的图片改成贵硬的参考图
哪张是原图
哪张是身份版
哪张是故事版
这里边不要搞错了
确认没有问题就可以生视频了
看到这里你可能会发现
如果把案例提示词
跟每次开始时的引导提示词拼在一起
那不就变成空用提示词了吗
说的没错
我也帮你都整理好了
之所以演示这个过程
是为了让大家理解一个更重要的思路
你看到的好的提示词
都可以用这个方式
融入到自己的工作流里
我以前还出过一个
逆向提示词的视频
搭配使用小狗登号
这就是本期视频的全部内容
我是居住士
带你发现有趣的AI玩法与洞察
我们下期见